when the Social Security Act was passed
in 1935 retirement officially began at
age 65 and the life expectancy at the
time was 58 so from the very outset
retirement wasn't exactly considered a
universal experience but over the last
century as life expectancies have
climbed the concept of retirement has
become synonymous with the final chapter
in a person's life then the book your
money or your life came out in the 90s
and introduced a pratical concept the
author Vicki Robin proposed that by
living with extreme frugality for a few
years younger people could essentially
become retired long before her old age
she claimed to have achieved financial
independence in her twenties today the
phenomenon of financial independence at
a young age goes by the acronym fire a
stands for financial independence retire
early and it's no fringe movement fire
has been covered by the New York Times
Market Watch and Forbes it's got more
and more Millennials wondering could I
quit my day job too
[Music]
this isn't about dropping out of society
or living in a cave necessarily fire
practitioners work extremely hard while
living far below their means for years
to amass enough savings to leave the
workforce and it doesn't mean you'll
spend your newfound freedom just hanging
out in bowling alleys like Jeff Lebowski
many people who manage to retire early
continue to work but only on projects
they're passionate about but the
question remains is it possible to
achieve through savings alone Pete a
denis aka mister money mustache no
relation might be considered the modern
fire movements founding father Aiden II
was working as a software engineer while
living dramatically below his means
during his 20s he took his savings and
paid off debt and invested it in stock
index funds by 2005 and in his early 30s
Aiden II and his wife had amassed around
$600,000 in a paid-for home he
calculated he had enough to leave the
workforce permanently Aiden he suggests
that early retirement is possible
through three fundamental concepts at
reality investing and the 4% rule of
withdrawals let's face it unless you
look into a large windfall of cash
you'll have to save up a serious nest
egg to retire and the simplest way to do
that is to slash your lifestyle
normally financial advisors suggest a 10
to 15 percent savings rate to retire at
a normal age of 65 or so when a retire
ahead of schedule then
have to level that up most early
retirees adopt a 50 to 75 percent
savings rate or more it's not uncommon
for them to cut restaurants and bars by
cheap cars bike to work let me do with a
smaller house and avoid luxuries like
gyms fancy vacations and expensive
copies simply stashing cash into a bank
account is a good start but the fire
proponents rely on the power of the
markets to boost their savings rates
assuming you saved your money into a
general stock market index fund you
might expect a 7 to 10 percent rate of
return based on historical averages any
experienced investor will tell you that
year-to-year return
swinging wildly maybe even crash so
that's where the third rule comes in a
1998 study by Trinity University
concluded that a 4% annual withdrawal
rate of your money in retirement should
allow you to never outlive your money
even in a bad economy this means that
even with the dramatic ups and downs of
the stock and bond market as long as
your yearly expenses stay below 4% of
your total savings you should be able to
live off them for well theoretically
forever
put another way you take your annual
spending needs then multiply it by 25
that's the amount you need to become
financially independent by now I imagine
you're wondering what it would take if
you wanted to retire early I think it's
time to run the numbers
let's imagine you have a household
income of $85,000 but you live way below
your means and only need thirty five
thousand year to be happy according to
our rule of four percent you'll need
eight hundred seventy-five thousand
dollars in the bank in order to be
financially independent through extreme
thrift and aggressive cost-cutting
you're able to save fifty thousand
dollars a year which comes to fifty nine
percent of your annual income at that
rate of savings and assuming your stock
index funds got an average return of 7%
you'll have hit your goal in twelve
years a good income frugal living and
compound interest are a powerful wealth
building combination you might be
wondering what if I don't make a ton of
money is this realistic a common
critique of the early retirement
movement is that a denis and other
leaders of the movement had high-paying
jobs in medicine or engineering making
big bucks can certainly speed up the
process but it's not a requirement
take Jillian John's read she began
working towards financial independence
at age 19
her husband served in the Armed Forces
and she worked in customer service and
sales over the next 13 years they made
an average household income of $60,000
with no year over six figures and by 32
Jillian had saved enough to be
completely financially independent
all while racing adopted and biological
children and climbing out of 52 thousand
dollars of debt she uses her freed up
time to travel the country right and
raise her children today she does some
work as a writer and coach but it's on
her terms if you think that early
retirement is all about lounging around
and avoiding work you've missed the
point instead it's about taking an
active step to replace a job you hate
with work you love and often finances
are the biggest hurdle as a Denis says
about the fire phenomenon early
retirement means quitting any job you
wouldn't do for free but then continue
right ahead and work in something that
works for you even when you don't need
the money and if you've already got a
fulfilling job you love
congratulations you already have the
benefits of early retirement without
having to save up for it so whether or
not you want to sprint toward early
retirement the mindset of reducing your
lifestyle living simpler and building a
more rewarding work life is something we
should all be aiming for and that's our
two cents if you were to retire today
what would you do with your newfound
freedom tell us about it in the comments
[Music]